[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend was heute in
Deutschland oder Welt passiert ist
erfahren Sie in den nächsten 20 Minuten
und den Sport den gibt es von Norbert
Lehmann einen schönen guten Abend
lange Stunden in Brasilien nach dem
Sturm auf Regierungsgebäude werden rund
1.200 personaro-anhänger festgenommen
schwieriger Aufarbeitung nach den
Silvester Krawallen in Berlin könnten
Ermittler Monate brauchen um die Beweise
gründlich auszuwerten
und Besuch an der Grenzmauer Präsident
beiden informiert sich an Texas über die
Flüchtlingslager an der us-südgrenze
nicht nur in Brasilien auch
international ist das in Sätzen groß
nachdem Anhänger und Anhängerinnen des
rechtsextremenexpräsidenten bolsonaro in
Brasilia unter anderem in den Kongress
eingedrungen sind und dort randaliert
haben von einem Angriff auf die
Demokratie spricht Kanzler Scholz als
ungeheuerlich verurteilt US-Präsident
beiden die Ausschreitungen
in der Hauptstadt Brasilia stirbten die
Demonstrierenden Gebäudekomplex in dem
sowohl das Parlament als auch der
senatagen dort sind auch die Büros der
Abgeordneten untergebracht außerdem
besetzen die Randalierer den Obersten
Gerichtshof und dem Präsidentenpalast
über Stunden konnten sie in den Gebäuden
wüten bis die Polizei die Lage unter
Kontrolle brachte
am Ende gipfelt der Kampf um Brasiliens
Demokratie in einem Showdown auf dem
Parlamentsgebäude mit Tränengas und
Gummigeschossen werden die Protestler
vertrieben zuvor hatte die
Militärpolizei stundenlang tatenlos
zugesehen
sie waren der Demokratie aufs Dach
gestiegen Radikale bolsonado-anhänger
die auf transparenten ein Eingreifen des
Militärs verlangen und nicht weniger als
einen Umsturz provozieren wollen
die Hoffnung dass in anderen Teilen des
Landes ist zu ähnlich in Attacken kommen
könnte um eine Situation der
Instabilität zu schaffen und dann
womöglich die Armee davon zu überzeugen
dass ein Putsch möglich ist die
angerichteten Schäden sind gewaltig
brasilias Platz der drei Gewalten
gleicht einem Trümmerfeld ob
Abgeordnetenhaus oder Senat
Präsidentenpalast oder oberster
Gerichtshof nichts wird verschont
wird sie haben sich wie wilde Verhalten
alles zerstört was sie vorfanden und es
gab zu wenig Sicherheitskräfte wir
werden herausfinden wer dafür
verantwortlich ist
ihn sehen viele als Drahtzieher der
Proteste Scharia bolsonano Lulas
Vorgänger im Präsidentenamt bolsonaro
hat sich in den USA abgesetzt und
bestreitet alle Vorwürfe friedliche
Demonstrationen sind Teil der Demokratie
Plünderungen und Überfälle auf
öffentliche Gebäude wie sie heute
stattgefunden haben fallen jedoch nicht
darunter
insgesamt wurden 1200 Menschen
festgenommen die sich am Sturm auf das
Parlament beteiligt hatten ein seit
Monaten bestehendes Protestlager direkt
vor dem Hauptquartier der Streitkräfte
in Brasilia wurde aufgelöst hunderte
bolzenario-anhänger mussten ihre Sachen
zusammenpacken und das Camp verlassen
Präsident Lula hat also ein hartes
Vorgehen gegen die Randalierer
angekündigt Christoph röckerath in Rio
de Janeiro was heißt das konkret
zum einen herr Präsident Julia
angekündigt alle juristisch zu
Rechenschaft zu ziehen die beteiligt
waren an der Randale gestern das
betrifft nicht mit Menschen die dort vor
Ort dabei waren sondern auch mögliche
Organisatoren und finanziert im
Hintergrund und das andere haben wir
gerade am Ende des Beitrags kurz gesehen
ist dass die gesamten Protestcamps im
Land heute aufgelöst werden sollen bei
diesem Camps handelt es sich um Lager
von bolzenario-anhängern die seit der
Wahl vor militär-kasernen in Brasilien
demonstrieren und campieren und um einen
Militärputsch bitten die hat man bisher
nicht besonders ernst genommen weil es
eine sehr kleine Minderheit der
Opposition ist aber jetzt werden auch
diese Lager geräumt das passiert im
Laufe des Tages bereits und bisher läuft
das ganze auch friedlich ab die Frage
ist natürlich auch wie sie rechtsextreme
nur schaffen konnten in die
Regierungsgebäude einzudringen inwiefern
haben die Sicherheitsorgane versagt
das ist die zentrale Frage die heute
ganz Brasilien beschäftigt und nach
ersten Erkenntnissen das ganze ist noch
recht früh scheint es eine Mischung zu
sein aus Fehleinschätzungen und
behördlichem versagen und möglicherweise
aber eben auch einer Form von Absicht
eventuell es ist so dass es Warnungen
vom Geheimdienst gab das Tausende von
bolzenario Anhängern auf dem Weg nach
Brasilia während gewaltbereite
bolzenario Anhänger es gab auch eine
Vorwarnung für die Sicherheitsorgane
aber die Frage ist warum die nicht
eingeschritten haben inwieweit auch da
die örtlichen Behörden damit zu tun
haben gerade die Militärpolizei vor Ort
wird geleitet von Menschen die sich dazu
bekennen bolzenario Anhänger zu sein
also warum die sich auch so
zurückgehalten haben das sind die
unangenehmen Fragen die jetzt Luder mit
seinem Apparat zusammen aufarbeiten
werden muss vielen Einschätzung
Christopher Gerard
der Sturm auf den regierungssitzen
Brasilia als Protest gegen den neuen
Präsidenten Lula Hintergründe zum Thema
und eine Analyse zu möglichen Folgen
finden Sie online oder in unserer ZDF
heute App
nach Deutschland fürs neue Jahr fassen
auch parteienvorsätze so treffen sich
sowohl die SPD als auch die Grünen
derzeit zu jahresauftaktklausuren sie
beraten darüber wo sie ihre politischen
Schwerpunkte setzen wollen denn vier
Landtagswahlen stehen 2023 an zudem
regieren SPD und Grüne ja in der
Ampelkoalition im Bund wir schauen auf
die Klausuren der beiden Parteien und
beginnen mit der SPD
zwei Tage in Klausur das hatte die
SPD-Spitze sich zum Jahresauftakt
verordnet zwei Tage mit neuen Vorhaben
für die Regierungsarbeit in der Ampel
Haupt Themen dabei wie die veraltete
Infrastruktur fit machen und den
Rückstand bei der Digitalisierung
aufholen hier brauche es viel mehr an
Tempo Züge fahren nicht mehr pünktlich
Brücken sind marode bei der
Digitalisierung hinken wir hinterher
schlechte Netze Bremsen uns aus und das
ist das was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
verdienen dass wir gut sind bei
Infrastruktur und deswegen wollen wir
einen neuen Schub neuen Schub den will
die SPD auch in Sachen Steuereinnahmen
denn der Staat braucht Geld die Krisen
Kosten erst Corona jetzt der Ukraine
Krieg die Steuerlast soll gerechter
verteilt und damit sozialer werden
niemanden zurücklassen alle müssen mit
gerade in Zeiten explodierender Preise
wir haben ein Jahr hinter uns in dem wir
große Summen auch in die Hand genommen
haben um erfolgreich Krisen zu bekämpfen
aber die verteilungs- und
Gerechtigkeitsfragen Rücken jetzt in den
Mittelpunkt und die SPD wird im Laufe
des Jahres 2023 darauf antworten geben
Antworten gibt die SPD auch beim Thema
tonausstieg daran wird nicht gerüttelt
die erneuerbaren Energien sollen Vorrang
haben Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine
ja allerdings nur in Absprache mit den
Verbündeten die SPD will ihr Profil in
der ampelregierung schärfen will als
Partei sichtbar bleiben schließlich wird
2023 auch in vier Bundesländern gewählt
auch die Grünen haben sich viel
vorgenommen für das neue Jahr die Ampel
hätte die Krise seit Kriegsbeginn gut
gemanagt die Grünen können Krise so die
heutige Botschaft allerdings soll
künftig der grüne Markt in Kern stärker
betont werden 2023 ein Jahr für den
Klimaschutz werden wir als Partei waren
stets der Meinung dass eine
Transformation hin zu Klimaneutralität
bringen notwendig ist und dass das nicht
nur ein Gebot ist das Klimaschutzes
sondern auch das Wohlstands und der
Wirtschaftskraft unseres Landes ist die
erneuerbaren Energien müssten schneller
ausgebaut der Kohleausstieg auch im
Osten bis 2030 vollzogen im
Verkehrsbereich mehr CO2 eingespart
werden so die Grünen Ziele die Räumung
und das Abbaggern des Ortes lützerath
und schön das Jahr aber Teil des
Kompromisses
für mich ganz klar im Fokus steht dabei
dass Deutschland bis 2030 bundesweit aus
der Kohle aussteigen sollte da müssen
wir jetzt unsere Kräfte bündeln uns
darauf fokussieren Konsens gibt es beim
Thema Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine
die grüne Friedenspartei trägt auch die
Lieferung der 40 Marder Panzer mit das
ist ein ganz klares Signal an die
Ukraine dass wir weiterhin an ihre Seite
stehen humanitär finanziell und
militärisch insgesamt habe die Ampel
viel erreicht über die Themen Atomkraft
und Tempolimit will man nicht mehr
öffentlich streiten gute Vorsätze die er
bekanntlich oft im Laufe des Jahres
gebrochen werden
die großratsche im Dezember brachte es
an den Tag Reichsbürger planten offenbar
einen Umsturz im Land und hatten dafür
viele Waffen gesammelt jetzt will
bundesinnenministerin Phaser das
Waffengesetz deutlich verschärfen ein
neuer Gesetzentwurf sieht vor das
besonders gefährliche halbautomatische
Waffen für Privatleute verboten sind
berichtet die Süddeutsche Zeitung beim
Kauf einer Armbrust müssten
Interessenten sich künftig registrieren
lassen und den sogenannten kleinen
Waffenschein vorweisen heißt es
neben der Diskussion um weitere
Konsequenzen aus der Silvesternacht
läuft in Berlin die juristische
Aufarbeitung der Übergriffe auf polizei
und Rettungskräfte
102 Strafverfahren wurden bisher
eingeleitet so die Berliner
Polizeipräsidentin Slowik generell haben
Angriffe zum Beispiel auf die Feuerwehr
zugenommen wie Henriette de Maiziere
berichtet
es ist nicht nur ein Problem Neuköllns
es ist nicht nur ein Problem von
Silvester in der vergangenen Nacht gab
es wieder einen Böller Angriff auf einen
Rettungsfahrzeug der Berliner Feuerwehr
in Berlin-Hellersdorf die Hilfe für ein
vermuteten Schlaganfall musste unter
Polizeischutz Erfolgen im Innenausschuss
des Berliner Abgeordnetenhauses ging es
heute um die politische Aufarbeitung der
Silvesternacht
gleichzeitig ermitteln wir jetzt mit
Hochdruck auf der Grundlage von
Videomaterial und kommen natürlich
ständig und stets zu neuen
Tatverdächtigen die weit über die andere
Zahl der 145 festgenommen die wir vor
Ort wirklich festgenommen haben
hinausgehen auf der Jahrestagung des
Beamtenbundes fordert
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer heute
die Polizei müssen konsequent in die
Brennpunkte gehen und die Justiz schnell
handeln
Straftäter müssen sehr schnell merken
dass ihr Fehlverhalten strafrechtliche
Konsequenzen hat deswegen ein schnelles
aburteilen dieser jugendlichen
Straftäter das ist das Maß der Dinge was
wir dieser Tage brauchen in Berlin geht
man in das davon aus dass die Ermittlung
zu den Tätern länger dauern werden man
tue sein bestes so der Leitende
Oberstaatsanwalt Berlins doch das ist
eine akribische Arbeit und die wird
nicht in ein oder zwei Wochen erledigt
sein wir reden eher von Monaten und so
sind die Forderungen nach schnellen
Strafen und der Umständen auch im
Kontext des Berliner Wahlkampfes zu
lesen
nach der Festnahme von zwei iranischen
Brüdern wegen der mutmaßlichen Planung
eines Terroranschlags haben
Einsatzkräfte auch heute keine giftigen
Substanzen gefunden
Spezialkräfte der Feuerwehr durchsuchten
zwei Garagen im Castrop-Rauxel die
beiden Brüder sind inzwischen in
Untersuchungshaft wir sollen versucht
haben Zyanid und Rizin für einen
islamistischen motivierten Anschlag zu
beschaffen
die Bundesregierung hat derzeit keine
Pläne der Ukraine Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Leopard 2 zu liefern das hat
Regierungssprecher Hebestreit heute noch
einmal klargestellt die Debatte hatte
vergangene Woche erneut Fahrt
aufgenommen mit der Ankündigung Marder
Schützenpanzer zur Verfügung zu stellen
in der Ukraine gehen Kämpfe und
russische Raketenangriffe weiter in dem
Ortschaft
im Osten wurde ein Markt getroffen zwei
Menschen starben mehrere wurden verletzt
beim Thema Einwanderung steht
US-Präsident beiden unter Druck auch
weil immer mehr Flüchtlinge über die
Südgrenze ins Land kommen laut
US-Behörden gab es zwischen Oktober 2021
und Oktober 22 mehr als zwei Millionen
Festnahmen an der Grenze zu Mexiko
vor allem Flüchtlinge aus Mittel- und
Südamerika hoffen auf ein besseres Leben
in den Vereinigten Staaten und probieren
irgendwo die fast 3.200 km lange Grenze
zu überqueren besonders viele sind in
der texanischen Grenzstadt El Paso die
beiden nun besucht hat MRT wissen war
vor Ort
Joshua scheint fröhlich dabei hat der
zweijährige mit seinen Eltern Miguel und
Joana zu Fuß und auf dem Dach von
Eisenbahnzügen mehrere Länder durchquert
viele hier sind aus Venezuela hoffen auf
einen Schlafplatz im Gemeindezentrum sie
fürchten sich vor der Polizei von
elsasso meine Neffen haben sie
geschlagen und mitgenommen seine
schwangere Frau auch
die Flüchtlinge rund um die Kirche
können jederzeit abgeschoben werden denn
wenn ihr zu Lana und jetzt auch Menschen
aus Kuba Nicaragua und Tahiti dürfen nur
von ihrer Heimat aus Asyl beantragen
kommt nicht zur Grenze so bei uns
Botschaft bei seinem Besuch in El Paso
versprach er mehr Ressourcen für den
Grenzschutz und für Hilfsorganisationen
Asylanträge soll man nur noch über eine
App stellen dürfen
beiden hören uns zu skandieren die
Flüchtlinge und bekommen dabei auch
Unterstützung von Amerikanern aus ihrer
Sicht untergraben die neuen Regeln das
Grundrecht auf Asyl
wenn sie mitten aus Verfolgung und
Gewalt fliehen wollen dann brauchen sie
erst einen Antrag dann ein Smartphone
Internetzugang ein Pass und ein Sponsor
in den USA das ist unmöglich für einen
Flüchtling
Menschenrechtsgruppen sagen Joe Biden
zerstört gerade all die Hoffnungen die
er selbst geweckt hat er macht es mit
seinen neuen Maßnahmen schwerer für die
Menschen Asyl in den USA zu beantragen
und eine grundlegende Reform der
Zuwanderungspolitik ist angesichts der
Zerstrittenheit in Washington schlicht
und möglich Streit droht auch beim
Gipfel in Mexiko beiden will das Land
zum sicheren Drittstaat erklären
Flüchtlinge die hier durchkommen hätten
keine Chance mehr auf Asyl in den USA
die mexikanische Regierung lehnt das an
für die Menschen in El Paso ist Mexiko
kein sicherer Drittstaat sie wurden doch
von Verbrecherbanden bedroht Joshuas
Familie ist froh hier Zuflucht zu finden
zumindest in dieser Nacht
so saß in weiten Teilen Pakistans vor
einem halben Jahr aus verheerend
Überschwemmung Millionen Menschen haben
alles verloren sind auf Hilfe aus dem
Ausland angewiesen jetzt hat die
internationale Gemeinschaft deutlich
gemacht dass sie Pakistan nicht alleine
lässt und mehr als 8 Milliarden Euro für
den Wiederaufbau zugesagt deutschland
ist mit 84 Millionen dabei Inger Rabe
und Marco berichten
Pakistan im letzten Sommer nach heftigem
Monsunregen waren die Fluten verheerend
Häuser Ecker und Straßen zerstört die
Schäden gehen in die Milliarden mit dem
asiatischen Land stand damals rund ein
Drittel der Fläche unter Wasser mehr als
30 Millionen Menschen waren betroffen
für viele ist es auch jetzt noch ein
Kampf um die bloße Existenz
die meisten von ihnen konnten noch immer
nicht in ihre eigenen Häuser
zurückkehren sie leben noch in Lagern
Hilfsorganisationen erreichen sie oft
nicht es gibt also immer noch viele
Menschen die keinerlei Hilfe bekommen
sie leben im Freien bei niedrigen
Temperaturen
in vericult
auf der uno-geber-konferenz in Genf gab
es nun hilfs Zusagen in Milliardenhöhe
Geld für den Wiederaufbau vor allem aber
auch dafür dass das Land für weitere
Katastrophen ausgelöst durch die
Erderwärmung künftig besser gerüstet ist
Pakistan ist ja sowohl von Überflutung
als auch von Dürren regelmäßig betroffen
und deshalb gilt es bei den
Überflutungen beispielsweise dafür zu
sorgen dass Regenwasser zurückgehalten
wird und bei den dürren gilt es
möglichst lang Wasser in der Landschaft
zu halten beispielsweise durch
wiedergewaltungen Wald zum Beispiel auch
entlang der Küsten Mangroven als
Bollwerk gegen Sturm und Fluten mehr
Schutz vor den Folgen des Klimawandels
ohne internationale Hilfe würden das
Länder wie Pakistan wohl nicht schaffen
zum Fußball Nationalspieler Thomas
Müller will weitermachen ja das hat dann
doch einige überrascht denn nach dem
wm-debat den Katha ja da gab es durchaus
Anzeichen dass der 33-Jährige das
Handtuch werfen will nun aber klare
Ansage in Bayern Trainingslager
ausgerechnet in Katha Thomas Müller bei
bester Laune genau 40 Tage sind
vergangen seit dem katastrophalen WM Aus
in der Vorrunde und der 33-Jährige hat
sich nun doch entschieden seine Karriere
in der Nationalmannschaft fortsetzen zu
wollen solange ich ähm Profifußballer
bin werde ich immer zur Verfügung
stehender Nationalmannschaft wenn nicht
gebraucht werde
das ist für mich auf jeden Fall völlig
klar
das wann das ob und das wie es muss
natürlich der Bundestrainer entscheiden
er stehe mit Hansi Flick im engen
Austausch will mithelfen wie der
erfolgreichen Fußball zu spielen in
welcher Rolle auch immer viele Fans wird
es freuen dass der Lautsprecher und
Sympathieträger weitermacht
und im Trainingslager des BVB Marbella
machen andere Spieler von sich reden
nach überstandener Krebsbehandlung steht
Sebastian aller wieder voll im Training
ja und auch der lange verletzte Marco
Reus meldet sich wieder Spiel bereit
sorgt aber durch angebliche
Wechselabsichten für Aufregung im
Medienberichten wird er mit Ronaldos
neuem Club in Saudi-Arabien in
Verbindung gebracht
und gelungene Generalprobe gestern für
die deutschen Handballer der 33 zu 31
Sieg gegen Island im letzten Testspiel
vor der WM entsprechend gute Stimmung im
Team von Bundestrainer Alfred Gießler
mit einer feuchtfröhlichen
Trainingseinheit haben die deutschen
Handballer ihre WM Vorbereitung
fortgesetzt der Island Test gibt
Auftrieb hinten ein starker Torwart mit
Andreas Wolf vorne ab und zu mal was zu
zaubern dazu ein junger Rückraum
Regisseur mit Torjäger Qualitäten wie
Juri Knorr der mit 13 Treffern
bestewerfer beim 33 zu 31 sieht aber
noch Schwachpunkte weil ich glaube man
hat heute auch wieder gesehen dass ein
paar Sachen noch nicht komplett sitzen
und das ähm ja das manche noch manchmal
Fragezeichen
haben oder ich auch was was spielen will
den 12 Platz bei der WM vor zwei Jahren
gilt es vergessen zu machen der
Asienmeister ist der erste Gegner am
Freitag in Polen Deutschland gegen Katar
zu sehen bei uns im ZDF ab 17:40 Uhr
selbst wenn es heute Nacht an den alten
und in einigen Mittelgebirgen etwas
schneit das winterintermezzo wird nur
kurz mehr zum wilden Wetter gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute schon mal
können Sie in diesem Abend um 22 Uhr
sehen mit Christian Sievers auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
frohes neues Jahr wenn für Sie zum
Winter unbedingt Schnee gehört dann
freuen sie sich vielleicht über ein paar
Schneeflocken die heute Nacht fallen
werden allerdings wird dieser Schnee
nicht lange liegen bleiben und das liegt
daran dass wir es weiterhin mit einer
westlichen einer südwestlichen Strömung
zu tun haben und dann geht's eben
wirklich nur ganz vorübergehend also
kalte Luft das ist auch schneiden kann
heute Nacht passiert das oberhalb von
600 m im Schwarzwald oder auch im Allgäu
sonst fällt Regen von der Nordseeküste
bis zur Donau und auch in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern der Wind kommt
das westlichen Richtung so wird es
wieder eine milde Nacht im
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen fünf Grad
z.B an der Ostsee und null Grad an den
Alpen dort liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen um drei Grad sonst
werden es vier bis zehn Grad und am
mildesten wird es mal wieder am
Niederrhein auch morgen Vormittag kann
es noch etwas Regen oder Schnee Regen
geben der zieht dann aber hier auch in
Südostbayern ostwärts ab dann wechseln
ihr Wolken mit etwas Sonne ab und am
Nachmittag kommen dann von Westen schon
wieder dichtere Wolken heran die bringen
neuen Regen und vielleicht Schneeregen
in der Eifel mit und dann regnet es in
den nächsten Tagen kräftig weiter vor
allen Dingen im Westen und im Süden
kleinere Bäche und Flüsse werden da über
die Ufer treten guten Abend